from casting and direction to props and
wardrobe every little piece involved in
a major motion picture becomes gilded in
history until the end of time but
although the hours of footage passes by
a thousand professionally trained eyes
sometimes a wardrobe malfunction skips
all of the censors and lands in the
final cut
whether no one noticed or the picture
was already locked these blockbusters
hit the big screen with wardrobe pieces
that were way out of place too bold for
the background Steven Spielberg's
Raiders of the Lost Ark keenly depicts
Egypt in the mid 1930s who knows a
thousand years even you may be worth
something but between the earth-tone
trinkets and the intricate tapestries
that lined the city markets one guy
totally blows the magic of cinema
just behind Harrison Ford's Indiana
Jones despot a guy wearing blue jeans
and a t-shirt casually passing by a
misplaced crew member or a
time-traveling adventurer you decide
undies from the future Russell Crowe
takes the lead in Ridley Scott's
gladiator as a general bent on vengeance
following the murder of his family my
name is Maximus Decimus Meridius
commander of the armies of the North
General of the Felix legions loyal
servant to the true Emperor Marcus
Aurelius
but what ripped some viewers out of the
moment however was the wardrobe
malfunction in the middle of a fight
scene where Crowes lycra shorts made a
guest appearance from under his tunic
which we suppose is better than nothing
what time period is it
starring industry heavyweights and
helmed by Academy award-winning
filmmaker Edward Zwick
glory earned well-deserved accolades
when it debuted in 1989 if tomorrow we
have to meet the judge Makino we died
facing the enemy critics lauded the
American Civil War set film for it's
breathtaking cinematography and enormous
attention to period detail praise which
comes off as a bit ironic today
considering the Wardrobe piece that made
it to the theatrical cut we're pretty
sure that digital time telling
technology wouldn't have been around in
19th century America but that wasn't the
only time a timepiece stole the scene
a Rolex out of time bear with us because
this one is really nerdy with its pitch
perfect soundtrack superb costume design
and fine tune set design David O
Russell's American hustle provides an
excellent snapshot of the sights and
sounds of the 70s the main cast seems to
have walked straight out of the disco
craze decade and so does supporting
after Louie CK except for one detail the
Rolex CK's character wears may look
super fancy but it isn't era-appropriate
it's a GMT master to Rolex with a
ceramic bezel first made around 2010
we'll finish the guys story another time
young man the erroneous earpiece Captain
America the First Avenger launched star
Chris Evans further into superstardom
and stands as one of the most well loved
Marvel movies in history
but in the midst of all the pokey action
and pleasantly retro vibe that the
critics applauded there's a historical
slip-up that surprisingly made it into
the film
right before cap and his crew raid a
Hydra train Kenneth Joyce character is
shown wearing an unusually high-tech
earpiece which definitely didn't exist
during World War two a little too much
skin even if you've never seen closer
you've certainly seen Natalie Portman's
character the exotic dancer from America
who arrives in London and falls for Jude
Law's character goodness stop being
cheeky in the final cut
she only flaunts a little skin but
thanks to a wardrobe malfunction a lot
more as shown while talking to Clive
Owen Portman's bras slips into not
suitable for work territory needless to
say it ended up in the movie anyway
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]